- ♫ Yo I need a little waffle with syrup,
♫ Diggy Ray here about
to spit all these lyrics.
♫ Get it in la la (sings in gibberish).
(techno music plays)
- [Woman w/o Mic] Pick
something out of this bowl.
freestyle about it.
- Pepperoni Pizza.
- ♫ If you know me I gotta
roll me up some reefer
♫ Order up a coca cola
then get pepperoni pizza! ♫
[Woman with Mic] - Yeah!!
[Woman w/o Mic] - Woooo!
♫ You know me I'm Sleazo and
I'm known to be a treater
♫ You see me in Ibiza
eating pepperoni pizza ♫
(women yelling appreciatively)
- Oh ♫ If I could be on a rocket ship
♫ Go away and take a lovely trip
♫ And have a lovely relationship ♫
- ♫ Mac and cheese mac and cheese
♫ I believe I could be your mac and cheese
♫ Mac and cheese mac and cheese
♫ Baby let me be your mac and cheese
♫ Let me mac and you cheese
♫ As I mac and I squeeze
your mac and cheese ♫
♫ Your mac and cheese ♫
♫ God bless you mac and cheese ♫
- Yes.
- ♫ Chips and guacamole
I get it from college
♫ Acting like you know
me when you don't know me
♫ You know you know homies
coming through the ♫
No, no (laughs), I got a few,
I got a few silly words, I got a few.
- Alright, ♫ It tastes so good
♫ And it's chocolate fudge sundae
♫ And I don't like to eat it on Sunday ♫
- A stapler.
♫ I was sittin' in the office
chillin' when I found that
♫ I needed to do somethin' with papers
♫ Couldn't use a rubber band
a paper clip wouldn't do
♫ So I went and found
my way to a stapler ♫
(Demetria laughs)
I really thought you
were working right now.
My God, that was amazing!
- Well then how the wha--